hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnusson invitational we are continuing
with the match Chikara nakamura vs.
Yandy polishing and this is the first
game of their match regarding the Giri
versus ding match I decide not sure the
Armageddon as well basically to make a
long story short Giri had the white
pieces dink had the black pieces the
game was drawn and ding won the match as
in Armageddon a draw is enough for you
to for you to win the match so that
being said let's check out this one and
Nakamura versus a nipple and this is a
game one of their match so II 4 by
Nakamura na po sticks to his French
defense with a 6 d 4 D 5 and the Knight
to c3 now I will Bishop to b4 the
venerable variation and at E 5 now so
the main line we have c5 a three
characters captures and now Knight to e7
and here are no funny h4 h5 business and
if Nakamoto goes for the old-school
Queen to g4 so immediately going after
the g7 pawn and here we have C capture
Sun before a very rare line or offering
this pawn while capturing there are of
course line with lines where you offered
the g7 phone I just haven't seen the one
where you first capture on d4 so rook
the g8 with Queen captures on h7 and now
Queen to c7 going down for that c3 pawn
and here in Nakamura just retreats Queen
back to d3 and now D characters and c3
and and Knight to f3 so this has all
been played before and here you would
continue with the Nightbeat to c6 or B
Bishop to d7 but the move nipple place
is a new move in the position he plays
b6 and it is as a move 11 that we have a
completely new game so it's it's a
really an awkward position but every
position in the French is an awkward
position so here what's the actual
compensation for black for giving white
this past H pawn well we'll just have to
wait and see so Nakamura also asks the
same question and he starts pushing his
passport with Bishop to a6
a going after this now going after the
Queen but this can only helps white as
white does have problems developing
you cannot move the bishop because of
root characters and g2 and this kinda
seems like it oh it almost helps white
so here Nakamura moves the Queen Bishop
captures an f1 and now King captures so
the king is now much safer and also
guarding the g2 pawn we have tonight to
b7 and now Nakamoto just continues
pushing the D past H pawn we have looked
the c8 and now just h6 the the past pawn
is a closer and closer to the queening
Square and now Queen the c4 with check
so this is basically the idea you play
Bishop h6 you trade for the King to f1
and now you deliver this check probably
something I probably something nipple
head over the board and then you will be
of course confident that you will be
able to stop the h6 pawn so Queen
captures and c4 roof captures and c4 and
now Bishop to g5 we looked the h8 now
putting the rook in front of the passed
pawn and now g3 we looked the h7 not
allowing the point to be pushed any
further as this Bishop might come to f6
at some point King to g2 nakamora
improves the position of the King and
now tonight the c6 with a double attack
on the e5 pawn so Nakamura defends it
with the rook rook a to e 1 and now b5
now nipple wants to start pushing here
a5 before and try to create a passed
pawn of his own on the Queen side so
it's a really really really wild opening
of course you have to know how to pull
it off if you want to play it and here
brush up to f6 now Bishop to f6 is is a
nice move and if you're not careful for
example if you give white a move then
you have to worry about him trapping
your rock on h7 and it's it's very
annoying it doesn't seem all that clear
how black will will get his rook out of
this
so instead nipple just captures it with
Knight captures pawn captures and here
rook the g4 would the idea of going roof
to g6 and going after these pawns and
here Nakamoto goes rook to h5 and nipple
probably thought that Nakamoto wants to
double up on the H file maybe go Knight
g5 kick away the rock and start pushing
the pawn and he went a rook to g6 to go
after the pawn and also put pressure on
this one but this however
is a bad move and I'm sure you can see
why it's a bad move without even pausing
the video so I will give a few seconds
but not now you know I don't think you
need to pause the video so here of
course a Nakamura played rook captures
on d5 is now at this point is free and
now this pawn was extremely important
it's basically what was preventing
Nakamura from reaching all of the other
points on the Queen side and now when
this point is gone now all of the other
pawns will fall so rook captures on f6
by Napo and now rook the c5 first before
grabbing the pawn so you move the you
force the knife to move back because if
the King defense then you have a problem
checking here and 95 just wins the
knight here there's no way to save it so
after rook c5 Knight back to e7 and only
now rook captures on b5 we have rook F
captures on h6 so the past one is
eliminated and now rook b8 check King to
d7 and now Knight to e5 with check King
to c7 and here just lucky to be one now
with some threats of of going route b7
check maybe tonight and maybe you can
win the night so here Knight to c6 by
nipple it's it's a hard position and
it's hard to find any moves for black
probably f6 or f5 is what what could
continue somewhat the game for black but
he ran a play Knight to c6 and this is
just this is just game over so feel free
to pause the video now and try to find
the the most correct line for white
which wins the game of course while I'll
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the fork and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook 8 the b7 check not
rook want to be some check because then
you leave your rook here to be captured
by the by the knight later on
so here the king is in check you don't
really have any good squares if you move
the King away from the defense of the
night then you just lose the night and
if King b6 then comes Knight captures on
f7 check and now you pick up the rook on
h6 or rather never just capture the
night and after rook captures on f7
it is in it was in this position that
the anypony she resigned the game why
did he
he's down the exchange and down upon and
of course he knows that a Nakamura will
have a very easy time winning this so
yeah that's game one in their match and
we're not gonna be showing other games
from their match as all three games that
followed were drawn so Nakamura wins
their match so there you have it ding
won the match against Erie and the
Nakamura wins against Knepper and before
I forget we should just check out the
standings before before we forget so
here are the standings from a
cross-table from the chess 24 web site
there you have it so Magnus Carlsen in
the first place with 11 points followed
by Nakamura with 10 the Fabiano Corwin
and England shared a third with 8 then
with 5 Maxime and Napo with 1 point and
if Yuri who got his one point after
reaching Armageddon against Bing leerin
and ali reza future still without points
but it's still early in the tournament
anything can still happen sure that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it it's
not that a nepos French was the problem
so as you can see as the position
evolves Nepos position became better and
better and even that Indian everything
just made sense even the special pace
sects forcing the King to f1 trade in
Queens and c4 and then you were able to
capture it but then he just wandered the
game away so it is very interesting this
French it almost almost gets me to try
and learn the French but I'm not quite
there yet but yeah I like I said I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Andrew Robson then Louis MLA
Govardhan Michael Reed and Chris Picard
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check too on my previous
videos here I'm thankful for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day